المنتخب المغربي تقدم في تصنيف فيفا ياسين
بونو الاكثر بحثا على انستغرام و غوري
يردوا على منتقديه هذه الاخبار وغيرها
نقدمها لكم من العربيه رياضه اهلا بكم
سجل المنتخب المغربي اكبر قفزه في تصنيف
فيفا بين المنتخبات التي شاركت في كاس
العالم وتقدم من المركز الثاني والعشرين
الى المركز الحادي عشر بعد تحقيقه اربعه
انتصارات وتعادل واحد وتعرض للهزيمه في
مناسبتين بين محافظه تونس على المركز
الثلاثين في التصنيف رغم فوزها على فرنسا
كما تراجعت قطر المستضيفه كاس العالم 10
مراكز فلا تعرضها لثلاثه هزائم
وبعد انتهاء المونديال نشرت شركه ميتا بعض
المعلومات عن المواد التي تم البحث عنها
على موقع انستغرام في الشرق الاوسط وشم
الافريقيا وتصدر اسمه ياسين بن قائمه
البحث عن الموقع مذبونا باشرف حكيمي وحكيم
زياش وكان عالم المغرب الاكثر استعمالا في
المنشورات والتعليقات بينما كان الدول
الاردن مصر والسعوديه الاكثر استعمالا
للعالم الارجنتيني خلال بطوله كاس العالم
بعد احتفاله بفوز منتخب بلاده بكاس العالم
مع اللاعبين في الملعب وفي غرفه الملابس
سيرجيو رده عبر حسابه على تويتر على احد
التعليقات خائنا لانه كان مع اللاعبين قبل
السنه وهم اصدقاءه ولم يتمكن من اللعب
معهم في سبب مشاكل في القلب لكن قلبه يسعد
اليوم ولم ينسى هذه اللحظات ابدا
يبدو ان المدافع ليفربول
الميداليه الفرنسيه وانتشر الفيديو وهو
يغني احداث اغاني انجليزيه كما ادى التحيه
الشهيره للحزبنا لم يكن وحيدا بل شاركه مع
السنه انتر ميلان تحياتي ذاتها وكان
الفيديو اخر قديم انتشارا للاعبين الكروات
وهم يغنون اغاني تدعم الفاشيه بعد فوزهم
على المنتخب البرازيلي